et comme nous le faisons
traditionnellement avant de vous poser
des questions je vais vous céder la
parole dans quelques instants pour un
propos liminaire d'une dizaine de
minutes en vous demandant de respecter
cette limite des 10 minutes tout
simplement pour que nous puissions vous
poser des questions le rapporteur david
assouline qui est à mes côtés sera le
premier intervenant de la commission
j'ai oublié de préciser mais je le
corrige on oublie tout de suite que
cette commission d' enquête a été
demandée à l'initiative du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine et
apport à porter david assouline
cette audition est diffusée en direct
sur le site internet du ca sénat et fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu qui sera
publié enfin je rappelle pour la forme
qu un faux témoignage devant une autre
commission denquête seraient passibles
des peines prévues aux articles 4 134
tirs et 13 14 et 15 du code pénal et je
vous précise également monsieur oui
qu'il vous appartient le cas échéant
d'indics d'indiquer vos éventuels liens
d'intérêts au conflit d'intérêts en lien
avec l'objet de la commission denquête
je vais vous invitez maintenant monsieur
ben brik a prêté serment de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité en levant
la main droite et en disant je le jure
je vous remercie et donc je vous donne
la parole pour dix minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
will est présent dans plus de 80 pays
dans le monde nous sommes actifs dans
plusieurs métiers vous l'avez souligné
ai confiance en rack 9000 collaborateurs
au 31 décembre 2020
willy réputé pour sa culture
d'entreprise c'est une dimension
essentielle dans notre pacte social et
bien entendu il est personnellement nous
sommes très fiers d'être est de très
loin le premier groupe du cac 40 à
l'importance de l'actionnariat salarié
les salariés sont avec 21,1 pour cent du
capital et 28,5 me penchant les droits
de vote
le deuxième actionnaire du groupe juste
après la société que le contrôlons avec
mon frère olivier qui a 23 8% du capital
et 29 6% des droits de vote à titre
personnel il était là mais directeur
brouille d'il ya trente deux ans soit
deux ans juste après la privatisation de
tf1 en septembre 1989
depuis le 10 février 2001 real c'est à
dire le ghana et la nomination d'olivier
roussat comme dirigeant gérard jeune
fille que le président non exécutif du
groupe
nous avons décidé de saisir
l'opportunité d'une fusion du groupe m6
je conçois fort bien que ce projet
risque soulevé un certain nombre
d'interrogations je suis donc là pour
essayer d'y répondre avec memo est à
l'étude il me semble que nous sommes en
question se pose d'abord pourquoi se
lancer dans une opération aussi complexe
que réunion entre tf1 et m6 tout
simplement parce que le métier de la
télévision qui efface une grande
mutation ton histoire récente et qu'il
est indispensable de croître au résister
et concerts la prière
le modèle économique de la télé gratuite
raconte traditionnellement sur un cercle
vertueux des audiences élevés permettent
d'obtenir des recettes publicitaires
solides qui elle-même y dans une
information de qualité et des contenus
variés lesquels soutiennent à leur tour
les audiences forte et ainsi de suite
mais il ya un problème
à chaque étape de ce raisonnement le
modèle se grippe dans les audiences nous
nous félicitons année après année des
succès car a bien sûr raison mais je
vous rappelle que c'est par l'audience
ne sont que malheureusement que les
chiffres relatifs en valeur absolue les
audiences baissent nettement au profit
les contenus digitaux car la
consternation de la télé le fait que
diminuer le nombre mondial de
téléspectateurs de 25 à 49 ans devant la
chante devant la chaîne tf1 en prime
time a ainsi baissé de 38% entre 2011 et
du coup logiquement les recettes
publicitaires ne l'intéressent times les
annonceurs ont cette évolution des
audiences ce report massivement longue
sur la publicité digitale
entre 2011 et 2021 les recettes
publicitaires et n'ont quasiment pas
bougé en valeur tandis que celle de
visitez chez en alternance ont été
multipliés par quatre et cela continue
enfin des contenus audiovisuels temps de
moins en moins accessible pour les
chaînes des grands studios américains
produisent des contenus exclusifs et les
garder à remettre au lendemain pour la
plateforme par ailleurs les coûts de
fabrication des oeuvres s'envolent les
noix sportive évidemment si je vais
mouvement
n'arrive et d'acteurs de taille
planétaire que sont les gars femme
change tout sans même parler des raisons
de changer de la sainte capitalisation
boursière de netflix représente 165
milliards de dollars en 2021 est égal à
100 fois la capitalisation boursière de
texte
ces bouleversements compte à terme plus
ou moins habituel économique et la
télévision il faut donc réagir pour
sauver ce modèle et inventer quelque
chose de différent
au franc ce que nous souhaitons faire ce
n'est pas grossir pour grossir nous
avons seulement besoin qu'on nous
permette de fertilité notre modèle si
les autorités de régulation
l'autorisation d'un groupe audiovisuel
ancré dans le territoire national et
dans le profil sont rares l'hybride
linéaires et non linéaires
la deuxième question c'est finalement ce
que ce courage fuyons peut-il peser des
risques sur le pluralisme et la liberté
de la presse
je voudrais d'abord dire que je ne suis
pas choqué que cette question se pose
elle me semble effectivement tout à fait
légitime et sérieux aussi j'entends dire
que le futur groupe serait beaucoup trop
puissant en matière d'information et que
tout cela serait extrêmement dangereux
alors soyons actuelle parmi les sources
d'information utilisés dans les français
la télévision aujourd'hui une place
beaucoup moins importante que par le
passé
une étude récente montre que si la
télévision est encore cité comme le
principal média sollicité par les
françaises depuis 35 ans pour sa forme n
48 % mais médias n'hésitant arrive
immédiatement derrière avec 30 de
consoles au sein des médias digitaux les
réseaux sociaux sur facebook twitter
avec pour la première fois dans les
applications mobiles des titres de
presse
si on veut garder pluralisme dans les
médias alors il faut donc parler de tous
les médias du reste même si l'on s'en
tient à la télévision il faut dire que
telle et rationnelle la chaîne hyper
dominant sur la fondation les sifflets
de la télévision publié par la rage en
2020 donc récemment montrent que les
journaux télévisés de tf1 et m6
représentent ensemble 34 % du nombre
d'informations diffusées quand les
jaunes les services publics sont
derrière france 2 france 3 et les autres
chaînes enfin
63%
ceci posé il est à mes yeux est vrai
parfaitement légitime d'être très
exigeant sans la liberté de la presse
c'est un agri essentiel qu'il faut
préserver
les journalistes de la rédaction
travaille librement la seule chose que
je leur demande c'est de faire leur
métier
je ne suis pas dicter une ligne de
conduite et vous le savez bien personne
ça n'est jamais clair j'ai mes opinions
personnelles bien entendu desana
intéresse dit les journalistes de la
rédaction ni à plus forte raison les
téléspectateurs
par l'inter nous poursuivrons dans la
même logique en protégeant la liberté de
la presse nous allons travailler de
l'art comme dans les mois qui viennent
imaginez les engagements que nous
pourrions prendre pour apporter des
garanties supplémentaires si cela est
nécessaire à pixel d'ores et déjà
prévues par la loi par exemple mais
aucun aucun aucun inconvénient à ce que
les journalistes différentes rédactions
du goût puissant cas de difficulté
saisir directement
de manière anonyme ou pas anonyme un
administrateur indépendant
man u a fait d'administration c'est un
chien n'a vérifié qu'aucune pression
internationale exercée sur les
rédactions et il y aurait un droit
d'alerté cette administration et tout ça
serait précisée dire évidemment dans le
règlement intérieur les français
d'administration jaune après que le
caire et puis
j'ai président et le rapporteur général
de la commission à tel ou tel un roc
audiovisuelle qui pour exprimer le site
infos service public qu'il à partir
d'une certaine façon opaque les moins de
ce pays
les autorités de régulation décideront
ce qu'elle décide de me décider je
m'endors je me bornerai vous dire ceci
le projet de fusion entre tf1 m6 n'est
pas un projet de puissance politique
médiatique ou économique c'est différent
c'est un projet de souveraineté
il consiste à bâtir en france un groupe
média qu'il puisse continuer demain à
informer et divertir les mentions vous
remercie
merci monsieur brigue première question
du rapporteur david assouline
bonjour monsieur bouygues
très content de pouvoir vous auditionné
ce matin je vous souhaite aussi un
prompt rétablissement
et
cette audition va être la dernière de 2
des auditions de grands propriétaires de
médias dans notre pays
je crois que ensuite ça va être nos
ministres qui ferment le ban de ces
auditions donc
elle était attendue bien entendu et on a
beaucoup parlé de vous que ce soit ceux
qui venaient analysées commentées
attracteur du secteur l'audiovisuel à
différents titres mais aussi vos
concurrents directs et autres grands
propriétaires de médias ont beaucoup
parlé de vous et de votre projet de
fusion qu'on a déjà aussi évoqué avec
monsieur pélissier avec monsieur
de tavernot et mes questions vous vont
déjà
vous savez que il y à un sujet de
concentration particulier en ce qui
concerne le groupe bouygues tf1 c'est
que
vous êtes au coeur d'une originalité sur
le plan européen ou international quand
même de 2,2
d'industriels qui dont le métier
principal n'a pas été les médias même si
maintenant il commence à y avoir une
ancienneté dans ce domaine mais
week c'est d'abord le bâtiment on va
dire et à chaque fois on se remet à
interroger ceux qui sont dans votre cas
sur les raisons qui vous ont poussé à
développer un groupe de médias
notamment avec l'interrogation
est ce que
c'est pour des raisons d' influence qui
permettra à votre activité principale le
btp et puis ensuite maintenant aussi la
téléphonie
qui dépend dans tous les cas de d'influx
ans
pour leur développement de rayonnement
de
voile à
s canton quand on vous dit ça vous
balayer d'un revers de main mais quelle
a été la motivation principale de cet
engagement pour vous et de sa
prolongation est maintenant de son
extension puisqu'il ya un projet pour
aller encore de l'avant
par rapport à vos autres activités et
qu'est ce que vous faites pour mettre
une muraille de chine entre ses
différentes activités
c'est ma première passionnant
pourtant je répondrai simplement
le gros bout il ya soixante dix ans et
ça fait 35 ans qu'il est dans les médias
ont fait la moitié de sa vie donc c'est
quand même je pense qu on a eu une
ancienneté
respectable alors
si oui quand il a fait le choix de
lancer ben brik dans la privatisation de
tf1 c'était tout simplement parce que il
voyait une opportunité
de s'intéresser à une entreprise qui
étaient publics elle tient avait été
géré de manière comme toutes les
entreprises publiques et c'est à dire
qu'ils n'étaient complètement en dehors
du milieu concurrentiel ils avançaient
que en tant que chef d'entreprise il
pouvait apporter à 7 ans à tf1 a une
vision différente de l'avenir et
profiter de ses fins dans un milieu non
concurrentiel et régis ctk
j'entends comme vous beaucoup parlé d'
influence
alors bon we believe he lequel pourquoi
comment furent dirigera est-ce qu'on le
procès - 21 d'être présents dans là
santé hommage à l'ex pro sen et pour la
sinn fein sais que c'est pas le cas vous
le savez bien donc je pense que kinshasa
avait parti un peu des chimères ça fait
partie un petit peu des tartes à la
crème qu'on se balancent un peu
facilement je rappelle que j'ai chaque
arrêt les six chevaux récemment sur
l'année dernière il me sens que
globalement la commande publique d'état
pour le gros bruit de représenter à
peine 7% du chiffre d'affaires et
peut-être un ou deux ans ont de la marge
vous voyez d'ornaisons des choses tout à
fait tout à fait limité ce n'est pas un
c'est pas du tout essentiel
dont vingt ans que
l'on faire des procès d'intention bien
entendu mais je ne pense pas que ce soit
un groupe on
veut simplement clarifier les choses
personne n'a jamais accusé d'avoir fait
une ingérence quelconque dans ou près
une question de quelconques sur les
rédactions du monde tf1 pour péter tel
ou tel sujet en contrepartie de jeunes
chez intel marchés publics
pour poursuivre est dans la continuité
de de ski de l'audition convient de
faire de monsieur xavier niel lui il n'a
pas mâché ses mots mais il a rappelé
aussi quelques chiffres qui sont des
réalités qui nous interrogent car nous
sommes sur une matière justement qui
n'est ni le bâtiment ni un produit de
consommation classique nous sommes au
coeur d'une matière très important pour
la démocratie et même pour la culture
dans notre pays pour la création pour la
cohésion sociale que sont les médias et
donc
la fusion entre vous et m6
c'est quand même un taux d'audience
très très important à des moments créé
puisque si on cumule les jt tf1
m6 le soir mais aussi à 12h45 et c'est
ça occupe quand même
grande partie des français est
comment dire
leleu
l'impact
aussi sur le terrain économique en
termes de concurrence avec à peu près 75
% de la part publicitaire
est en général
votre argumentation première et vous
l'avez rappelé mais on a entendu
beaucoup
et à l'interroger il faut pas la balayer
d'un revers de main mais en tous les cas
les questions doit vous les posez c'est
le marché international avec la
concurrence des daf et donc il faut
avoir une masse critique de de puissance
pour pouvoir résister avec m6 vous
pensez être en meilleure situation
vous savez que cela est contesté puisque
ils sont sur un marché international qui
n'est pas complètement comparable au
marché français et en particulier du
digital que ça vous met en position
dominante quand même sur le marché
publicitaire français de l'audiovisuel
et en général on avance des arguments
que vous avancez quand on est en
mauvaise situation or vous avez
développé l'idée que vous êtes en
situation difficile puisqu'elle est
perte d'audience
on nous a affirmé que depuis dix ans
votre audience est à peu près stable et
quand même 6 à progresser donc que
répondez-vous à sa déjà en terme
d'audience
la situation n'est pas dos au mur
catastrophe sur la question des
résultats financiers on constate aussi
que les résultats sont bons même si on
prend comme référence l'année avant le
qu'ovide
ccd bons résultats il comprit qui vous
permette d'investir et qui vous
permettent de verser des dividendes aux
actionnaires donc l'argument principal
qui est ça va mal donc on se met en
situation de
de fusion presque de monopole sur le
marché privé
semble être critiquable que répondez
vous à ces arguments qui sont avancés
par des gens très divers pas seulement
par vos concurrents
religion l'audition est le nom de
monsieur niel bien entendu tout et
c'était assez choqué parce que
finalement il ramène un peu toutes les
histoires d'argent de son argent et qui
m'a un peu choqué mais bon chacun a ses
conceptions de la visite en ce qui
concerne
les 75% de marché publicitaire
64 enfants de la république c'est la
télévision en clair oui
santé à 100 % des recettes de tf1 m6 est
100 % des recettes m6 soyons sérieux
sachant de combat le marché n'est pas du
tout celui que vous écrirez que le
marché et c'est le marché qui nous
concerne sept marchés de la télévision
est un fait mais de les dissocier n'a
aucun force
j'aimerais juste monsieur
oui mais je me suis fait pour qu'il y
ait des précisions qu'on s'entend bien
c'est pas aucun sens ça n'existe pas
existé a jusqu'à présent ça a été comme
ça que le marché a été jugé pertinent
par toute la jurisprudence de l'autorité
l'argent donc maintenant vous le
contester l'autorité de la cour la
réponse mais c'est pas une aberration
que de dire ce qui a toujours été
jugé comme marché pertinent
que ce qui nous intéresserait par le
passé c'est plutôt des chiens je portais
dans la grille si je me permettais alors
je me suis fait sortir ainsi que tout ça
la recette de la chaîne télé recettes de
publicité de la chaîne tf1 était de 1
milliard et demi en 2011 et depuis trois
ans elle est aux alentours de 20
milliards en garde les médias 250 oui
qu'en dix ans la recette de publicité de
des vins ne cesse de croître alors que
sa part d'audience parmi les chaînes de
télévision en clair vous l'avez soulier
reste stable et que sa part d'audience
parmi les autres médias en ce compris
digital ne cesse de croître elle joue
l'équipe pour la raison pour laquelle
nous nous inquiétons devant les recettes
de publicité
baissé ça c'est une réalité
ces chiffres sont disponibles quelle fin
et jp les changements sont dus le
voulait commenter et on pourra vous les
fournir évidemment finement j'ajouterai
que monsieur niel a beaucoup employé le
monopole le tien monopole en parlant des
fascistes il ou ils occultent le service
public qui est gros alors quand on
retire tour effectivement il reste de
l'album cela évidemment un grand enfant
non c'est un peu gros vous pouvez dire
c'est important mais d'un côté vous
aurez 41% après la fusion ait eu ces 31
ou 32
mais c'est important mais plus rono
on vous laisse continuer oui
si je m'ennuie
je suis
les mains bien
avant
dès maintenant le monde courra les
décideurs avons rempli une fois les
avions
déjà une
question essentielle et menacer de mort
au moment de servir du mois en effet le
moine aucun des partis qui refusent les
éleveurs millions
[Musique]
vs c'est
alors
nous voulons vous êtes inquiétudes moi
en tant qu actionnaire de référence et
les fins et maintenant le grand mes
responsabilités mais responsable et elle
n'est pas
si
nous mangeons quel joli nom
vision et m6 nous avons fait tout ce qui
n'est pas du goût à ces fusions sont
face
à leur
couper les cheveux blancs
et nous avons
connu dans cette fusion nous paraît
essentiel même si ce fut chaud le croate
des
grandeurs salle et une cérémonie
rituelle et nous mérite et non le vrai
les chances à la socam idée
mais je vais sortir les chipmunks 17 de
google
une fois mais le chiffre à 15 tours
et châteauroux vannes où ils sont
démunis dont elle sort d un vent
puissant et nous on est des sujets
importants depuis son élection
je déjeune mission
de changer le jeu
nous avons auditionné
monsieur olivier ont ça dans un autre
cadre au sénat
mais c'était très intéressant seconde a
pu nous exposer et notamment il nous a
dit que d'ici 2027 33 34 millions
de prises fibre optique devrait être
installée
l'ensemble des foyers devraient être
ainsi connectés permettant des échanges
le site de volume de données très
importantes la publicité ciblée pour
ainsi se développer at il dit tout en
précisant si même si le robot hic ne
croit pas à la convergence entre les
activités d'opérateur et de diffuseurs
les métiers étant jugé très différent
monsieur roux ça reconnaissait néanmoins
que la compétence de l'opérateur en
télécommunications permet d'anticiper
des usages et des tendances donc il y
avait bien un lien
de fait même si vous ne l'indiqué pas
clairement la convergence des tuyaux
contenant et contenu ne constitue-t-elle
pas votre
réponse de fond à la montée en puissance
des gars femme est votre projet
important
et qui justifie aussi
cette fusion et m6 mais aussi votre
propre développement sur les activités
où vous étiez déjà vous pensez bien que
ça aussi est prise en compte dans notre
réflexion
sur les concentrations puisque
en 86 quand la loi était fait
personne n'envisageait qu'il y aurait
les tuyaux et et 7 et des boxes etc et
l'internet et que vous vous avez vous
êtes en position forte pas seulement en
terme d'audience est un sujet qu'on
vient d'évoquer mais en termes de 2,2 de
présence sur l'ensemble de la chaîne de
création de valeur
de
l'acheminement jusqu'à la production et
l'édition
votre projet stratégique en gros ma
question c'est on a beaucoup parlé de la
fusion tf1 m6 mais globalement c'est
aussi un projet faso de la femme qui de
là pour moi semble semble plus plus
réelles parce que sur la télé gratuite
on ne peut pas dire que netflix doit
être un concurrent par contre sur la
question de la convergence que vous avez
fait un autre métier où la production et
l'édition et les développements que vous
êtes en train d'envisager je vois bien
la réponse que vous voulez apporter ce
que vous pouvez nous développer un petit
peu votre
votre projet stratégique
de l'ensemble de la convergence
non non non
comme nous avions vraiment
très
content delivery
fisher dans les six mois
mais j'ai un
problème avec la création entre deux
images
pour les horreurs
au réseau internet
là
[Musique]
vous voyez juste une invention de
problème quand on dit quand même que
dans pour pr pour la la la la
concurrence pour la démocratie le
pluralisme il ya un sujet quand c'est le
même propriétaire qui possède les tuyaux
la création la production et l'édition
c'est à dire sur l'ensemble de la chaîne
des valeurs et les propriétaires de tous
vous pensez que la ja ja arment
s'invente un sujet c'est possible que
vous le pensez mais ma question que je
vous ai posé aussi tout à l'heure c'est
justement puisque votre réponse et de me
dire il n'y a aucun rapport entre tout
ça s'est il même pas de pensée
stratégique autour de sa
part ce sont des activités autonomes
pouvez nous dire comment sous séparées
sur le plan formel
l'ensemble de ces activités
leur semble de fait fin est une filiale
de huy contrôlé à 40 avançant de quoi et
donc avec des actionnaires extérieurs
tellement des comptes tout âge
régulièrement oui quel homme est une
fille anne oui quand rené à 80 11 % par
le bruit avec donc des actionnaires
extérieurs également entraîneur non élus
lama compte et a pas mélange déjà entre
les deux bien évidemment mais on savait
toutes les chaînes de télévision où tous
les diffuseurs qui le souhaitent ont
accès aux boks italie comme étant des
règles qui sont parfaitement définis à
fondre parfaitement clair et sans aucune
limitation qui que ce soit
je voudrais et sur
celle affichée
par la diane keaton et harrison
contre les chemises et il nous attend là
il me dit quelque part en france mois la
moitié des choses et elles sont réelles
à une conception et je tiens absolument
à ce que
les machines entre
les parents
et l'enfant jésus est né de chez rien de
division c'est l'autre
si vous vendez
gratuit aux diffuseurs
son minaret était intéressante venir
donc elle tramain jeunesse et sports
d'hiver à nier toute relation entre
le connecteur ça venait
le temps de définir à coutras objectif
de faire de l'audience les diffuseurs
guillaume moreau et pendant ses nerfs et
donc ça c'était vraiment y faire voilà
ce qui manque à la panoplie
de l'étranger les meilleurs pour
l'équipe et il salutaire car il y en
[Musique]
ait non de la mer les traducteurs
indépendants
ferment les usines ils les étages et les
fantaisies l'ensemble de l'est jean
michel génial à travers l'internet et ça
aidera les premiers une fonctionnaire
estime t elle ils peuvent réussir à
traiter
dans
lequel puiser dans une émission et le
poids du chômage
il faut exonérer les vendeurs
correctement notre vision
à ce niveau alors je gèle
un soleil très certainement à ceux qui
veulent nous acheter j'ai bien compris
j'ai bien compris ce donc ce serait vous
allez me dire si si c'est une vue de
l'esprit ou si c'est envisageable de
façon pour eux précise le plan de
généralisation de la fibre et d'abandon
du cuivre d'ici 2030 présentée par
orange ne constitue-t-il pas une
opportunité pour votre groupe de
présenter une offre couplant accès et
contenus ça vous passe par la tête c'est
pas du tout un projet vous le ferai
jamais ce sont mes questions vous allez
vous oriente très jamais là-dessus
je vais juste vous demander si oui de
vous rapprocher du micro parce que par
moments nous entendons à sémalens je
sais pas où et vous votre micro mais si
vous pouviez à l'approché savent pas si
ça doit être un peu mieux oui merci
donc ma dernière question de cette série
j'en ai toujours une porte de la toute
fin mais celle là c'est une question
qu'on imposait à chaque fois on n'a pas
eu de réponse peut-être vous avez vous
une réflexion déjà plus avancé
bon on sait très bien que
cette fusion va obliger
votre groupe a cédé des chaînes puisque
le maximum ses 7 et que l'addition tf1
m6 fait 10 est-ce que vous avez une idée
sur les chaînes que vous pouvez mettre
sur le marché
et même qui peut être intéressé
par ou qui prend déjà contact avec vous
si c'est pour pour pour être candidat
la possession de ces scènes à l'achat de
ces chaînes
je l'aimerai le monde
d'une manière en première mi temps nous
n'avons pas réussi encore que les télés
gêne possible de la cdc l'émission les
entoure bon j'ai menti c'est
effectivement nous avons des discussions
en cours je ne comprendrais que tout ce
que je peux vous dire qu'ils ne dans
quelles conditions
retenez un petit élément de
intéressant ce monsieur n'est un vin
à l'armée mi temps comme une fusion
totale puisque vous traitait
notamment son rang contre elle
le prix tu as vu d'ici kenyan tva auquel
on se réfère tu fais passer le chiffre
digne a
compté vingt mille 20 ya investi 15
millions d'euros
l'appartement est réelle il y à deux
fois l'enfant selon lui donc je vous
vois là
bas je ne voudrais rebondir sur la
question du rapporteur concernant les
chaînes que vous pourriez cédé dans le
cas de la fusion tf1 m6 jusqu'à présent
il avait été évoquée sister tf1 série
tfx ou glee ddd des chaînes qui je crois
a été évoqué ici même dans cette
commission denquête par des
représentants tf1 vous nous dit ce matin
que ce sera pas forcément celle là qui
seront mis en vente
d'accord c'est bien une consultation qui
a d'ores et déjà été engagées
je vous pose joujou pose cette question
parce que dans dans le cadre des
remarques qui sont faits sur le taux de
concentration pourrait engendrer tf1 m6
évidemment tout le monde a remarqué que
celles qui seraient mises en vente si
bien entendu c'était celle que j'ai
cités sont celles dans les taux
d'audience sont actuellement les moins
élevés que ça aurait pu être une réponse
pour
la par rapport à la concentration
importante de vendre d'autres chaînes
dont le taux d'audience sera un peu
prisée des grands
noms mais je pensais à d'autres
mais je te préviens d'autres amis
mais ce que je suis pas je suis père
condamné y il se trouve que nous étions
trop acide et la longueur la classe
ouverte et j'ai moi même un chien google
tandis que les nouveautés le griot n'est
malheureusement son décès mais non je
suis le seul qui en est dans la crise a
un effet inattendu george hill et la
première est mieux y aller glaner shell
a trois enfants ça existait là nul à
lens est dans cette idée pendant le
deuxième où elle s'était classée les
systèmes aussi une école de formation
pour les journalistes devraient
nourricière et si vous regardez les gens
de la presse tunisienne
aujourd'hui voulait énormément par lille
où commencer par essayer et je n'ai pas
à me lâcher et donc je me suis
incliné devant larry valeur et on va
exiger un dénommé on aime beaucoup
discuté un ministre at-il
moi je voudrais vous poser une question
sur la question du marché publicitaire
nous avons fait une table ronde dans le
cadre de cette commission denquête il ya
quelques jours avec différents acteurs
du secteur publicitaire
cette table ronde était très riche donc
je peux en faire un résumé mais moi j'ai
retenu quelques points notamment le fait
que pour eux la publicité à la
télévision aurait resté inégalé en
termes d'efficacité comme message passé
capacité de diffusion de du message et
l'un d'entre eux à un moment on dit que
l restait même pas cher par rapport à
justement à son efficacité
est ce que dans les prévisions que vous
faites en cas de fusion comme en cas de
non fusion du reste il ya l'hypothèse de
l'augmentation du tarif de la publicité
sur vos chaînes
vous avez même temps le times l'a vu
cette révision enfants dedans et grime
en
deux éléments
auront au sort puisqu'il parle google
devenir conquérante et les tarifs sécu
pas un hasard si facile parce que vous
êtes allé dans un très compétitif
l'agente publicité des annonceurs
identifie précisément les
investissements
publicitaires et voilà hélas non
le coût efficacité le meilleur
récit ce qu'on voit sa vérité même si
grand que ça à des comptages sont des
tarifs élevés
enfin m6
sur un autre sujet nous avons auditionné
thomas sera peu il y a quelques jours
dans le cadre de cette commission
denquête et qui nous a dit que si la
fusion tf1 m6 se se faisait elle
pourrait donner lieu à d'autres
rapprochements au niveau européen je
crois qu'il a cité l'allemagne est me
semble-t-il aussi de mémoire le le pays
bas on verrait ainsi se structurer un
certain nombre de groupes à taille
européenne
est-ce qu'il ya selon vous des
perspectives en matière de coopération
entre ces futurs champions européens
les synergies en collant ou de manière
par exemple des gogos qui n'avait jamais
le conseil des grands indien
religion et leur nature
quand même un déficit est longue
moi personnellement je suis tout à fait
le défenseur de la france il ne tournait
maintenant
nous faut nous posant
de manière de l'information est
évidemment
de divertissement d'origine française en
c1 existe aussi des synergies entre
européens je pense que
le mouvement avait assisté aux deux mois
d'avancé à la france qui n'avait qu'à
gérer
des autorités wallonnes titre pas à me
décider
si c'est une mission qui devant
l'ancienne hamiti métrage mais on est en
vie mais sans oignon de dire qu'on n'a
pas le temps de la réflexion pour en
rire le suit à des délais
d'inscription 2 et du lot
je peux mais ce qui vaudrait d'ailleurs
à ce sujet les vendre aux salariés de
l'entreprise parce qu'ils sont violents
les deux aussi de tendance je vous
laisse imaginer cela représente comme
situation
d'inquiétude pour les salariés de
l'entreprise qui veulent en donnant on
va savoir l'échangé terminé je n'avais
entendu mais leur laminé répète souliers
d'emballage mois que oui mon a depuis
longtemps été fermés tessier agi seul on
a essayé leurs affaires en italie avec
des groupes de jeunes
talents différentes et c'est maryse
argent
michel logique merci monsieur le
président que ce week bonjour j'ai bien
également écouter l'ensemble de vos
propos depuis les débuts de vaud de vos
interventions donc on voit bien dans la
concentration il y adeux il ya deux
sujets il ya le sujet économique avec
notamment la publicité et bien sûr tout
ce que coûtent les produits et puis il
ya aussi le pluralisme et l'indépendance
des rédactions
puisque ça fait aussi partie du travail
qu'on doit faire au sein de cette
commission est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui c'est suffisamment
fort chez vous est-ce que vous pensez
que dans le cadre aujourd'hui de la
concurrence le plus importante que nous
avons il faut doter l'art comme de
compétences supplémentaires et puis
puisqu'on parle pluralisme indépendance
vous avez au sein de votre groupe
un comité d'éthique en fait vous en avez
deux nous avons appris hier que vous
aviez deux il ya un premier qui se situe
au niveau de la rédaction et un autre de
manière plus générale dont nous a parlé
hier madame edith dubreuil elle a dit
aussi d'ailleurs qu' il n'y avait aucune
saisine à son niveau est ce que vous
nous expliquer pourquoi chez vous il ya
deux comités d'éthique et pourquoi il
n'y a aucune saisie d' alors que vous
êtes quand même la télévision européenne
de la plus importante et puis je
voudrais aussi
évoqué avec vous
simplement le choix du président de la
nouvelle entité si l'iaf si la fusion
s'avère
puisqu'il y avait quand même la
possibilité d'avoir des cieux pélisson
ou nicolas de tavernot comment comment
s'est fait le choix sur nicolas de
tavernot
répondre
sur une copie de villepin et jean louis
chaussade
considéra comité d'éthique où ça chaque
quotidienne du groupe oui j'ai pas
landreau l'ancien fonctionne bien cette
fois c'est un leur élégance et les
stations qu'elle choisit allemand à
denis parent dépendant président du
comité l'outil qui est chargé dans les
doléances quand il y en a de préserver
leur animal social le bervet la marina
de lignes enterrées lankaise si
éventuellement scène j'ai fait c'est
bien une bonne solution
et voilà vous paraît pas pensé
les noirs comme problème la réponse est
claire je n'y vois que les avantages et
inconvénients et non tranchante le web
je mets bien au contraire je suis
réveillé à l'indépendance de la région
tel un jeu 100 kg y compris dans des
gagnants lln à prendre quatre ans j'en
ai rêvé du barrage de la thur et
finalement ça s'est bien passé et donc
je vous mentirais avec ses filles on est
chez les rênes de transmettre ma vision
du problème à mes successeurs l île soit
un jour là rien ne va pas demander
la filière et le maire les enfants
des surveillants de la rédaction mais
les nouvelles demandes et au large sera
à sa part grand
consensus
étant ici de la démission d'angel le
score est lourd d'ouvrir la
génération ancienne et très belle
qualité sans vous savez il a été d'abord
un collaborateur ni quelle heure ils
nous avaient dit qu'elles aimeraient
pourtant la résidence des rares dit
daniel leopard a fait satisfaisant je
remercie et qu'en fait vendre et les
bananes de l'influent imam en algérie il
était inutile de gym loisirs la
personnalité révèle qu'ils étaient les
rois incontestés 1.6 et qui avait le
visage identique et à l'intérieur
d'autres il a cette caractéristique ces
gallois incluant les anciens du pénal
français résident parce qu'à un prêt d'y
aller super non elles allaient de c'est
comme ça il est compétent ce unanimement
reconnue dans ses pelles
sur le sait que la vision d'une
entreprise de
quelle époque de plusieurs éléments que
le nouveau revu
l'intermittence pour
gérer les sens a accepté de revenir aux
côtés de sa soeur oui quels
qu'ils soient
oui je suis chira or nous les et
motivant
rejeter les femmes de manière
un peu différent de celui de la métier
et région ça d'un très riche voilà le
choix mais je pense qu il faut qu ils
veulent un seul de mes chances de
réussir la télé
monique de marco
si merci bonjour monsieur bouygues bon
on n'a pas eu un un sens parfait dans la
salle alors je reviens quand même sur
les propos de xavier niel qui a été plus
loin qui a dit voilà tu es fusion tf1 m6
ça sera un monstre qui va faire la loi
c'est quand même des mots très très fort
pourquoi parce qu'il a et vous avez en
partie répandu sans avoir répandu
concernant donc les tarifs publicitaires
vous nous dites d'un côté que le tarif
publicitaire est le plus bas en france
par rapport à l'europe en même temps que
les recettes publicitaires ont diminué
en dix ans
donc normalement pour rééquilibrer tout
ceci ça va dans le sens d'une
augmentation dans de la publicité jeu
selon vos propos je ne vois pas d'autre
solution donc une première inquiétude
dont de monsieur niel deuxième
inquiétude c'est les producteurs de
séries et des missions qui craignent eux
pour le prix de l'acquisition de leurs
de leurs programmes qui vont peut-être
baisser si jamais il dit si jamais la
fusion tf1 m6 se faisait il y aurait un
vrai duo paul avec de service public
d'un côté et de l'autre côté donc un
seul groupe qui représenterait en tout
90 % des achats et à partir du moment où
vous avez qu'un seul client il est
évident que qui fixera les prix cette
inquiétude de la donc cette production
pouvez vous donc les rassurer je reviens
juste pour un complément de ce qu'a dit
michèle losier sachez quand même que
eddy dubreuil la magistrate de votre
comité d'éthique a dit simplement
qu'elle ne servait à rien qu'il ya eu
zéro saisine c'est quand même donc une
rumeur qui fait que ans s'interroge sur
le bien-fondé
de ce comité d'éthique au sein de tf1
faudrait-il pas justement lui donner les
moyens de pouvoir donc se saisir du
dossier voilà et ma dernière question
parce que là je m'inquiète parce que je
suis abonné à salto et en cas de fusion
il est fort possible que france
télévisions se retirera
donc comment voyez vous donc la suite
justement de cette plateforme salto
comment peut-elle rentrer en concurrence
et sachant quand même que je suis
surprise
on ne peut pas visionné salto au delà de
la frontière française y at il pas quand
même quelque chose à revoir pour que ce
soit un produit une parka de forme qui
soit intéressante est que quand je vais
en vacances en espagne en italie ce
puisse visionner et profiter de mon
abonnement je vous remercie
et militaires je
marchais le temps par le génial
le concernant
je ne me rends pas
compte a été
incendié il est passé sur une chaîne qui
monte sachs en liberté dans une émission
les cérémonies d'y aller c'est sûrement
et donc peu par hasard sur agen qui
n'ont jamais réellement un repreneur
mais nous ne heureusement un peu
d'entrepreneurs et celle entre des sites
dont je rêvais gt5 est le référent sur
une image qui donne est mince par
ivoirien place pas moins d'éternelles
j'amènerai l'aller mais
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne
sa
maladie enfin nous des réformes morale
internationale et qui ont des hommes
ordinaires c'est vrai mais qui
les produisent sont d'accord
fédération que je fais maintenant daniel
compétitive et attractive
et qu'elle sera là pour ce faire les
produits pandemrix où toutes les filles
noté l'instant la diffusion moi je
trouve le soutien c'est normal
lundi musique française qui consiste à
nier que
les créateurs sont totalement
dénonçant un système qui les nourrit
rares sont les obligations 300 personnes
je suis pour que les enseignants je
pense que ce n'est là
aussi c'est la france est de créer des
gens totalement dépendante du de la
commande publique ou privée mancelle je
pense aussitôt à l'international le gros
du marché et les années
de la même manière dans lequel quoi
s'étonner de voir
celle qui a été commandé par le saint
esprit
finalement c'est d'un transfert d'argent
public pendant la crise divers stands en
contrepartie match des 18 ans je peux
vous en faire tout un cours en arts et
en journée
sur le central le comité d'éthique bages
nous au plr
un
comité d'éthique gérer les déchets j'ai
rien dit il tout ce qui va dans je vais
bien me convient pas
et salto messieurs rien à
voir la mine appartient pas il
appartient
gilles pélisson une vingtaine d'ong
ainsi à neutre je vois qu'ils veulent on
n'a rien d'un taux bas à
dévorer qui sonne il sélectionne les
concerts
le genre les enceintes évident mais on
verra t il quand même je fais dans la
simple aimant autant de talent inouï
c'est le tandem avec m il ya alors des
ministres administratives et ont été
extrêmement le monde et qui à mon avis a
ajouté
m
la loi
genevoise sur d'autres plaintes au
sujet des contenus en jour les
frontières donc je pense que je
suis
et line renaud garabédian glyn
oui merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur bouygues en septembre dernier
daniel chritine ce qui était déjà
propriétaire de plusieurs titres de
magazines en france elle marianne a
augmenté sa participation
chez lui pour atteindre 5%
cette montée au capital des fins il fait
sans concertation avec votre gauche les
pour citer monsieur crise qui se nenê se
défaire en aucun cas dans un cadre d'une
hostilité
selon certains médias une rencontre
aurait déjà eu lieu en 2010 autre jour
et monsieur crédit de ski durant
laquelle je ne fais que de citer la
presse il vous aurait fait part de son
intention de racheter 10% du capital
enfin un projet qui n'a finalement pas
abouti comment percevez-vous
l'investissement de monsieur crédits
inscrits à vous merci de votre réponse
je vais nulle est immense les quelques
temps il ne fait pas un projet déjà rien
que le fait que vous voulez
qu'il fasse éjecter en beauce je le veux
je n'ai pas pouvoir est une question sur
les agréments baptiste vient d'annuler
terrien tessin je peux marcher
vous vous savez si c'est
justement aucun pouvoir jb remis à lui
rappelé que les vins vie toute votre
origine de la loi crée la tisane
j'ai très bien frappé et nous voilà
alors j'ai lu comme vous l ai dit qu'il
aurait pu qu'il avait fait 5 ans en
désert mais voilà
je pense que si l'état français
toujours
sans succès l'actionnariat de semenya et
la lettonie mais semblerait tout à fait
utile je pense qu'il ya déjà les couacs
existe peut-être utile à l'enfance elle
je pense que cette révision qui ne
paraît pas actions de l'indien quand
même vous savez bien ce que j'aime la
commission qui est en danger
mais si vous n'avez pas encore parlé
dans les motivations de duras proche
parent éventuelle fuite tf1 m6 des
enjeux en termes de maîtrise de la
technologie
or quand on écoute monsieur rabeux et sa
stratégie chez bertelsmann lui place
tout de suite les enjeux en termes de
maîtrise technologique mais comptant
quelque chose de deux principales de
l'essentiel est ce que vous nous
confirmer le chiffre que nous a donnée
monsieur pétition en début de semaine
d'un investissement annuel à venir en
cas de fusion de deux d'une dizaine de
millions sur des sur les des la maîtrise
technologique et j'allais dire ce qui
peut me permettre de faire 1-1
appréciation de seulement une dizaine de
millions ce qui peut paraître peu par
rapport aux halles à la puissance corps
est le nouvel le nouveau groupe
l'idée essentielle car éventuel jeu
favori serait il peut conserver nos
investissements pour améliorer la
maîtrise technologique de l'enfant on va
voir les clients n'avaient cependant on
apprend que jean stratégie channel on a
une à une activité communication entre
les 1,6 et nous on ne peut pas parler
c'est qu'on est difficile de faire des
choses pareilles mais ce que l'on sait
par contre c'est le livre un regard
on savait que les positions sont tous
péri galère qu'on va faire un inventaire
de logis à vendre et nous chatrak un
humiliant type saas 15/4 et nous
continuerons à le faire donc
en permanence un outil de veille à
l'international par l'agglo où cela
reste embrouillée puis 20 ans on a une
cellule t bag nouvel avenir en
californie et qui fait de l'arrêté
définissant tournée dans l ain un poids
médias les gars et on a la même cellule
évincé a confié la même chose
place et donc
où quand même beaucoup davantage touche
à sa fin quelles sont les voies d'un
développement et de ses possibles
on alloue l on attend d'autres ans
développeur et donc nos sillons et nous
pensons qu'il ya ou pas laisser nos
vaches avec un taux de fer elle si sa
portée allez-vous et en sus de ses
filiales importantes avant le lendemain
je
continuerai pas dans mon sort
david assouline
oui merci on arrivait à la fin de cette
audition gg de deux petites questions
une remarque
je suis frappé par la férocité
de la concurrence par exemple entre vous
et monsieur niel et par la férocité des
mots des reproches des sous-entendus
parce que vous voyez bien que
l'objet principal
du débat sur la concentration que vous
initiez
reste celle de faire face aux
plateformes étrangères et donc d'unifier
un petit peu des grands acteurs français
et on se rend compte que ça ne fait pas
trembler du tout les plateformes
étrangères
mais par contre que ça suscite
une concurrence intérieure et que ça
c'est peur surtout à l'intérieur le
fêter à nouveau un nouvel grands acteurs
que vous envisagez
je vous rappelle quand même puisque vous
ai cité des chiffres
que la principale concurrence qui
pourrait les concurrents c'est assez
grande plateforme se fait effectivement
sur les investissements des capacités
capitalistique d'investissement puisque
c'est le nerf de la guerre l'argent dans
des domaines qui coûte très cher
et que on évalue pour le seul netflix 17
milliards par an et que l'audit et que
vous avez créé sera à peu près un
milliard 3 et je parle que d'un acteur
de ses plateformes si on devait prendre
les autres acteurs se seraient plus de
100 milliards par an et donc ont rapport
avec le 1 milliard 3 tf1 m6 et tout cela
c'est pour pondérer
le la nécessité de la fusion qui que je
n'aurai pas de mot à dire je ne suis pas
un décideur c'est entre les mains
d'autres autorités mais dans les
arguments qui s'échangent entre les uns
et les autres quand même ramener
les choses à leur juste proportion
je voulais poursuivre sur un domaine qui
est celui de 2
de l'indépendance des rédactions et de
la spécificité cas le domaine médiatique
quand il s'agit de pluralisme
d'indépendance de liberté
l'attention qu'on doit y porter de façon
particulière
c'est clair et reconnu que les
rédactions de tf1 lci sont des
rédactions
des os solides d 1 action
professionnelle
reconnue comme telle
qui qui travaillent de façon tout à fait
efficace et qu'il n'y a pas là de
polémiques tels qu il peut y en avoir
avec d'autres groupes en ce moment
notamment dans le groupe de monsieur
bolloré
ceci dit vous ne répondez pas
complètement con vous dis bon moi je
n'interviens jamais et c'est bon on sait
très bien que que que il yad'autres
d'autres choses qui des fois
sont un nuage au dessus des rédactions
c'est
l'autocensure quand il y a un
propriétaire qu'il ya d'autres activités
par exemple j'ai jeu m'a alerté sur
quelque chose j'aimerais avoir votre
réaction et en plus je vois très bien
que que la chose est possible le groupe
bouygues a été condamné définitivement
le 12 janvier 2021 pour recours à un
travail dissimulé sur le chantier de
l'epr de flamanville cette affaire ne
pas complètement anecdotique puisque
selon l'ancien directeur du travail
hervé guichaoua l'état estime avoir
perdue au bas mot entre 10 et 12
millions d'euros de cotisations sociales
non versées
pour autant aucun média du groupe tf1 a
évoqué ce sujet par exemple
donc on peut se dire bien entendu que
vous n'avez pas passé un coup de fil
pour dire ne traitez pas ce sujet mais
on peut se dire que il ya des sujets qui
vont toucher à vos activités qu'on va
pas trop aller chercher
dès que le problème que je vous pose ne
se réduit pas est ce que monsieur niel
peut parler sur tf1 ou peut pas parler
c'est c'est un sujet structurelles à
partir du moment où on est dans des
activités industrielles importantes qui
touche à beaucoup de choses dans notre
pays
la façon de traiter les informations
concernant ses activités pour un gros
pied
propriété du responsable de ses
activités est un sujet indépendamment de
vous ou de votre
volonté ou pas d'intervenir ce serait
pas vous peut-être que il interviendrait
puisqu'il en aurez la possibilité oui ce
que je veux dire donc sur ce cas
particulier vous avez quelque chose à me
dire
[Musique]
que je
suis moins sûr
gérer est le plus fort
prenez-vous mais c'est ma question c'est
que les acteurs français
qui qui eux vont être écrasés dans
l'histoire c'est à dire que j'ai bien
compris ce que vous dites mais il ya
d'autres acteurs en france que vous donc
si pour pouvoir résister aux plateformes
vous dites on doit on doit prendre tout
en france ça peut créer un quand même un
problème de pluralisme pour les acteurs
français
de
vraiment donner
chez
nous ce biais nous concentrer leurs
immenses et la dernière de téléphone
comment
je continue avec sa collègue josée
métier c'est pas bien
j'en action urgente et vitale est un
authentique
d'exil présidence oui j'ai démonté fdlr
n'ont pas connu le sol est trop jeune
mais quelle était la fin du financement
au gré des articles litige parce que
l'art et la foi que tottenham aucune
chance à des degrés divers ont été
conservés tout venu et je me suis alors
la suivante je suis allé un jour alors
est là dans le droit de retrait que là
ils avaient été mutilés
m'attendais à quelque chose jacques a
dit qu'il est noir et écouter ses traits
saint
géry à la qualité d'un crédibilité la
rédaction tf1 est donc bien entendu chez
toi qu'elle traînait aux informations et
je les vois
mais vous vous voyez bien que la
question se posait qu'ils avaient besoin
que vous que que vous lui répondez à
cette question ce et si vous aviez pas
répondu peut-être qu'ils auraient décidé
de son de s'autocensurer
dans la manche ou de tout et de rien
cela révèle un problème alors dans
le visuel jeter des choses il y a
genestet l'arménie en tulle et il nous
n'avons ni chez un artisan
actions
tiennent à la mer à laquelle nous avions
jugé
sa longueur ou
chez la nounou
et je pense qu'on a fait le tour
bien monsieur oui merci merci des
réponses que vous nous avez apporté et
donc vous renouvelle nos voeux de prompt
rétablissement d'un
merci
mes chers collègues
nous nous retrouvons alors attendez
juillet toujours vous le dire mercredi
mercredi 16h45 avec roselyne bachelot
fois la console monory
voilà retour en salle des conférences un
vrai et puis suivre en direct et en
intégralité depuis 11h30 cette audition
de martin bouygues le président du
groupe éponyme et et on a entendu un
martin bouygues qui a relativisé
l'importance du poids de la fusion entre
tf1 et m6 si elle devait avoir lieu bien
sûr il ya eu beaucoup de questions et on
a entendu à la fin cette audition sera
question de l'ingérence de bouygues dans
le travail des rédactions de tf1 et
martin bouygues qui a été très voilà
rassurant pour les sénateurs les
journalistes des rédactions de tf1 font
leur travail en toute liberté a pu dire
ce
président du groupe bouygues et il a
ajouté j'entends beaucoup parler d'
influence et de s'interroger laquelle
comment et de les qualifier de chimères
ou encore de tarte à la crème enfin je
voulais vous livrer cette dernière
citation de martin bruit qu'on a entendu
dans cette audition personne ne m'a
jamais accusé de faire une ingérence
quelconque ou une pression quelconque
sur les rédactions de tf1 pour traiter
tel ou tel sujet en contrepartie le
jeune c'est qu'elle marchait public ça
n'a pas de sens mais on a entendu un la
méfiance du rapporteur socialiste david
assouline c'est la fin de cette émission
n'hésitez pas à lire tous les comptes
rendus de cette audition et le tout les
autres de cette commission d' enquête
sur le site de public sénat c'est
publicsenat.fr trabelsi de programmes
sur public sénat
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
l'actualité parlementaire et politique
continue sur publicsenat.fr
ça y est nous y sommes comme tous les
cinq ans la france choisit son président
et comme tous les cinq ans il y aura des
programmes des phrases assassines des
coups bas des renversements dans
l'opinion bref tout ce qui fait le
charme et le piment des campagnes
électorales tout ce qu'on analyse en
détail avec les invités ils ne sont pas
d'accord vous allez le voir et c'est
tant mieux et maintenant 2022 c'est ce
soir à 22h je compte sur vous
[Musique]
bonjour tout ravi de retrouver au menu
de cette édition le club et territoires
à l'écart nous venez défier le rédacteur
en chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire pierre jacqmin avec ton
chef de la rue on va parler d'humanité
emmanuel macron annoncé hier un retrait
des militaires français du pays ce qui
n'a pas manqué de faire réagir les
candidats à la présidentielle on verra
tout ça et en parlant de la campagne
présidentielle à cette semaine
maintenant du premier tour semaines de
petites trahisons entre a dit marine le
pen lâché par son porte parole nicolas
bay anne hidalgo lâché par ségolène
royal qui lui préfère jean luc mélenchon
n'en parlera évidemment l'actualité dans
nos régions ce sera du côté de vichy
avec mathieu perrineau du journal la
montagne et puis dans 40 minutes notre
invité politique jean christophe lagarde
le président de l'usé hic parti lui le
centriste des propos tenus par valérie
pécresse dimanche la soutient-il
toujours sans condition on lui posera
bien sûr toutes ces questions et on
commence à un club des territoires kitty
la mnt première mutuelle santé et
prévoyance des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans les
transitions 0,15 mené région vous
présente le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales at vous présente le
club des territoires et oued ont
commencé en parlant du mali sujet qui
s'est donc invitée dans la campagne